[Music]
with legal migration to the UK reaching
unprecedented levels Sky News can reveal
allegations that criminal gangs are
putting people on planes and trafficking
them by exploiting visas for skilled
workers
we're calling this woman Mrs a when we
meet she's urgently seeking legal advice
claiming she's just one of the victims
who handed over extraordinary amounts of
money to come to the UK to fill
Britain's job vacancies she had no idea
this was going to happen
Mrs a says she paid what she thought
were Recruiters in Sri Lanka the
eye-watering sum of 65 000 pounds to
arrange work in Britain as a carer when
I go to the airport they gave me the
work permit and the ticket and a boy Mrs
a says at the airport the recruiters
gave her a 12 year old boy who she'd
never seen before and was told he had to
travel with her
she says they used a fake Sri Lankan
passport for the boy and falsely claimed
he was her dependent so he could travel
on the work visa they've secured for her
it was last minute I felt very scared
but couldn't do anything about it
I didn't understand much
it was only after I arrived in the UK
that I realized it was a big mistake
Mrs I says when they landed at Heathrow
Airport the boy was met by people she
didn't know and she never saw him again
Sky News has been told about a number of
similar cases where the entitlement to
bring dependence on a skilled worker
visa is being abused
just a few weeks ago another woman it's
claimed also flew to London on a work
visa and brought three people with her
posing as her husband and children
the woman in that case has now
disappeared but our investigation has
taken us North in search of the woman's
fake family
we traced the man who pretended to be
her husband to Staffordshire and have
identified him as a 48 year old Sri
Lankan rice farmer who's now claiming
Asylum I'm not eating everything
tencent not to leave Mom do you see my
best his name is rather he says he paid
someone who he calls an agent fifty
thousand pounds to get him to the UK
where they told him he would have a job
and after a couple of years residency
foreign
how easy do people in Sri Lanka think it
is to exploit the British Visa system
s
in attempting to trace the false
dependence listed on that one UK work
visa we find Sri Lankans dispersed
around the UK
in Liverpool we've Tracked Down The Boy
Who Says agents made him travel as
rather's fake son
this is 19 year old hinthujin he's now
living with relatives in the cities Sri
Lankan Community he cuts a small and
frightened figure
he says his family had arranged for him
to come to the UK but had no idea he
would have to pretend to be the
dependent of a stranger until he got to
the airport in Colombo foreign
[Music]
there are now questions about the way
visas are issued it's extremely alarming
and concerning that we have a system
that is not catching exploitation at
this level and there needs to be some
way of the home office reviewing its
systems to look at what's not working
here but remember Mrs a who we met at a
solicitor's office
urgently in need of legal help
her journey to the UK doesn't only raise
allegations about people smuggling there
are now questions about the regulation
of the skilled worker visa system
Mrs a was given a UK residence permit
although she doesn't meet the only
requirement to come to the UK from
abroad to work as a carer to speak
English
Sky News has obtained these documents
used to support Mrs A's job application
by the so-called recruiters she paid
her own legal advisor has told us the
documents are entirely fake
Mrs a never completed a three-year
diploma course in nursing neither did
she pass exams in physics biology and
chemistry these forged certificates
State that Mrs a obtained a very good
pass in an English Language exam Mrs A's
fake CV boasts she spent seven years
providing direct nursing care to
patients in a busy Hospital Ward
environment and two years providing care
to patients in a home for the elderly it
says she's skilled at safe patient
handling and first aid none of this is
true
almost 150 000 people came to the UK
last year on skilled worker visas in
February 2022 carers were included on
the government's list of jobs needing to
be filled
it was that opening up of the jobs
Market post brexit which also brought
this family to the UK
seat seat but vinothan and his wife and
two young children are now living in
this spare room of someone they know
because he says the job he thought he
was coming to do didn't work out
vinothan says he received a letter
saying he'd successfully secured a post
as a care support worker for 40 hours a
week on induction day he was given a
uniform but claims he wasn't told before
leaving Sri Lanka he would have to do
unpaid training for an unspecified
period of time before getting paid work
now in dispute with the company his
certificate of sponsorship to work in
the UK has been withdrawn and he's
claiming Asylum
they Nathan says he paid people in Sri
Lanka 26 000 pounds to arrange the job
his entire family's life savings so you
thought they were recruiters you didn't
know there were criminal gangs when you
gave them the money
but why did you think recruiters would
charge you 26 000 pounds because uh I
asked them because this is a very huge
amount I thought I am getting my Visa
genuinely I care with the expectation of
job means it's a very very very big
amount for us from Sri Lanka because my
grandfathers my grandmothers Jewels two
three generations
they've earned that inside don't have
anything now everything has
they have cheated
we've spoken to both the companies who
separately sponsored Mrs a and vanoton
to come to the UK they insist they've
done nothing wrong and have no
connection to the people in Sri Lanka
that Mrs a and vanothan say they gave
money to
consequence of all of this is that
recipients of skilled working visas are
ending up in Britain's Asylum system
the home office says it's reviewing the
skilled worker visa process as a result
of our report
a spokesperson said we are actively
investigating the claims made abuse of
our immigration system will not be
tolerated anyone who's used false
documents misrepresented their personal
circumstances or practice deception by
any other means we'll have the
application refused
Britain's buckling Asylum system has yet
more complex cases to unpick this wasn't
how those who gave vast sums of money in
the hope of securing new lives in
Britain hoped things would work out
Lisa Holland Sky News